all right also tonight fake news CNN
they're at it again now Anna Navarro far
left political hack who once pretended
to be a Republican strategist actually
accused uh Nikki Haley of being fake uh
yeah right take a look
let's put that much stuck on anything
she says because she'll she's always
contradicting herself just a little bit
afterwards right whenever I hear Nikki
Haley it's I the the song plays on my
head you know well the real Nikki Haley
please stand up because she will say
whatever what does she stand for that's
what I'm saying
she stands for whatever is convenient at
the moment
Anna Navarro sits around trash talking
Republicans that's what she gets paid
for now meanwhile Nikki Haley was a U.N
Ambassador under Trump was the governor
of South Carolina now some are
speculating that she is plotting and
planning maybe a run for president for
2024. let's give a warm Hannity Show
welcome as Ambassador Nikki Haley
governor Haley is Willis
fabulous
they didn't clap that loud for me uh no
great to see you we've been friends a
long time and do you even want to
respond to Anna Navarro who really cares
what she thinks no I'm happy to respond
because the funny thing about her she's
first of all been anti-trump forever
secondly she loves to go through on The
View as well when she's not doing that
but they can't stand the fact that a
minority female would be conservative
they want me to hate Trump all the time
and the fact that I don't they find that
highly offensive and they also find it
highly offensive that I have a brain and
that I can say when something is good
and that I can say when something is bad
and I'm not going to be a puppet for
anybody let's talk about 2024. I know
you're on with Brett Bair earlier this
week
um it looks like you're running I
suspect you're running I don't know for
sure but if you want to make your
announcement now I think a lot of people
will be happy
um are you thinking about it as fun as
it would be to announce right now um yes
we are I just got rejected go ahead
we are leaning in I mean look it is time
for a new generation it is time for more
leadership it is time for the fact that
we really start to take our country back
we cannot have another term of Joe Biden
and we have to remember too we have lost
the last seven out of eight popular
votes for president it is time that we
get a republican in there that can lead
and that can win a general election let
me ask you this so right now president
Trump is the only announced Republican
candidate uh he is a very strong
following among the Republican base you
know that polls show that uh we keep
hearing Ron DeSantis name we keep
hearing Glenn younkin's name we keep
hearing Mike pompeo's name uh Ted Cruz
might make a run for I don't know at
this point it's a little early I feel
like we just got over the last election
to move on to this one
um what would you say are the
differences let's start with President
Trump make America great again America
First agenda what what policy
differences do you have with him well I
had a great working relationship with
him I consider him a friend we you know
most of the policies that he did I
totally agree with
um and you know there's going to be
other Republicans in the race most of
them are my friends you know let the
best woman win
that's a good line
is there anything specifically off the
top of your head that you would do
differently or that you disagree with
them on what I will tell you is we have
to look at the fact that mothers can't
find baby formula we've got families
that can't afford groceries we've got
kids who've lost so much in education 70
percent of our eighth graders in this
country are not proficient in Reading we
don't have the backs of our Law
Enforcement Officers we don't have
enough border patrol agents and you look
at the fact that we surrendered to
Afghanistan and our foreign policy is a
mess we have got to hunker down as
Republicans but more importantly As
Americans and say this is not the way we
want to go does everyone agree
Republicans need to change and alter the
way they run elections pay more
attention to balloting more more
attention to early voting voting by mail
do you all agree with that all good okay
Governor uh Ambassador great to see you
thank you thank you guys hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else